hello everyone we are pleased to have
you join us at the cardinal health lab
exchange welcome to today's live
broadcast personalized medicine
comprehensive next-generation sequencing
for cancer patients I'm Bob Woodruff lab
roots and all be your moderator for
today's webinar we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
Cardinal Health Cardinal Health is a
fortune 22 company that improves the
cost effectiveness of healthcare as the
business behind healthcare cardinal
health helps pharmacies hospitals and
ambulatory surgery centers clinical
laboratories and physicians offices
focus on patient care while reducing
costs enhancing efficiency and improving
quality Cardinal Health employs more
than 34,000 people worldwide for more
information please visit www com we have
a few important announcements to make
before we begin this presentation has
been approved for continuing education
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner of the auditorium
this will direct you to the necessary
site and form needed to receive your
credits this webcast is designed to be
interactive we encourage you to ask
questions during the presentation you
can skew can't submit questions by
typing them into the Q&A box which can
be found by clicking on the green Q&A
button from the lower left-hand corner
presentation screen you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon on the lower right of the the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or listening to this
presentation please click on the support
button in the upper right hand corner of
the presentation screen you can also you
know send us your problems you're having
in the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the Q&A button following
this presentation head over to the
community of learning in the lab extry
change lobby to have the opportunity to
exchange a live chat and have your
questions answered on the spot about
personalized medicine comprehensive
next-generation sequencing for cancer
patients I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Steven while dr.
Lyle is molecular diagnostics lab
director at Q group he is a physician
physician scientist with expertise in
the histopathologic cellular and
molecular analysis of cancer he holds an
appointment as associate professor of
cancer biology and pathology at the
UMass Medical School and is the
co-director of the UMass Cancer Center
tissue bank dr. Lyle graduated with
honors from the University cago in a
combined be a MS program in biochemistry
and then attended the Pritzker School of
Medicine University Chicago where he
completed his MD and PhD in biochemistry
and molecular biology he served as a
resident and surgical pathology fellow
at the University of Pennsylvania
Hospital or he received the prestigious
HT underlying fellowship award he then
completed his clinical training as a
fellow in the Harvard derma
dermatopathology program in Boston would
you please join me in welcoming dr. Lyle
to today's presentation I will now turn
the presentation over to him thank you
Bob I appreciate that introduction and
I'm going to get started with the
presentation Bob appreciate that
introduction and I'm going to get
started with the President on top
personal vows Russell
so it seems silly there's a sound issue
okay so here are the objectives for this
afternoon stock so one of the most
important points to make today is that
patient to receive precision therapies
survive longer and this has been
demonstrated in this report in journal
of american medical association studying
lung cancer patients he received
targeted chemotherapy and calm when an
oncogenic driver was identified as you
can see here there are significant
responses when patients received
precision therapy gefitinib and patients
with metastatic lung cancer and
presumptive in patients with metastatic
disease really dramatic responses to
targeted therapies when an oncogenic
driver is identified showing here is
just a list of the approved fda approved
to targeted therapies that are available
for functions you may not be able to
read this very closely but just to point
out that there are a number of
fda-approved drugs that target specific
genes and genetic pathways however
currently single gene tests exist for
only a relatively few number of targets
of precision medicine you're probably
all familiar with me wrath and test from
the code last method out one which can
be analyzed by fish in egfr irby to buy
fish and pcr so i currently just a few
single gene tests are available however
there are additional tests are being
developed and
and that's the point of our talk today
there's also some limitations of current
testing there's a limited range of
genetic alterations that are detected by
the current tests sir Prince it's less
common but still clinically significant
changes may be missed for instance it's
estimated that only ninety percent of
beer applications are represented by
v600e and thus ten percent of clinically
significant mutations are missed by
current testing modalities in addition
the need for serial testing requires
more tissue which may be limiting or
prohibitive for patient testing and and
thus additional black sea's may be
required also the current testing
modalities do not get the entire range
of potential actionable alterations I
just know genes have been identified
recently that aren't encompassed by the
current testing modalities and also
there are dozens of clinical trials for
instance in melanoma that require
molecular profiling to identify uncommon
genetic alterations such as in C kit
Kirby to ms and fgf RS another important
point to make today is that the latest
caper Cancer Care in the u.s. is rapidly
evolving currently about 1.6 million
patients are diagnosed with advanced
cancer and this number is expected to
increase in 2017 importantly eight
percent of these patients are treated at
community hospitals or community ecology
practices instead of large academics
cancer centers where molecular
diagnostics is routine also the
knowledge of cancer genomes is rapid
increasing at a pace due to the TCGA and
other large-scale sequencing
projects simple gene testing or hotspot
testing to determine optimal therapies
are becoming inadequate as they are
being recognized as inadequate and they
miss many critical genetic or genomic
changes that are relevant for developing
therapeutic approaches the guidelines
for National Cancer Center network are
changing turn through next-generation
sequencing based testing and lastly many
new clinical trials involve testing
hundreds of genes in depending on
next-generation sequencing profile these
are so-called basket trials and we'll
talk about that more shortly just to
point out here evidence from the Cancer
Genome Atlas research Network which was
really an extensive project to molecular
leak air characterized a number of
different forms of cancer by a number of
different techniques and valuing for
many different genomic alterations and
we like comprehensive regular analysis
of cancer and this has led to a
tremendous amount of information on the
genetic alterations in cancer that are
targetable just shown schematically here
genomic alterations effect actually
while signaling pathways that are common
in solid tumors including one cancer
breast cancer colorectal cancer melanoma
and so a number of genes that are
targetable have been identified for
these cancers that were unknown several
years ago for instance in lung cancer
targeted therapies for all these genetic
alterations are either approved by the
FDA by not too drunk today or will
shortly have an fda-approved drug
available with its targeting specific
genetic alterations
just specifically looking at mutations
in melanoma of course everybody's
familiar of erath that has been shown
recently attend Mass nf1 seek it and hrs
are also very important in targeting
targeted therapies for all these
alterations are currently either
approved or are in clinical development
and hopefully will be approved shortly
importantly these mutations are new to
us mutually exclusive and thus we need
to test for all of them with every no
known location again looking more
carefully at melanoma there's been a
number of additional genes that are also
cated that are not being exclusive but
also are actionable including p53 p10
map kinase ins and so there's a number
of clinically significant genes that are
altered that are currently missed by
current testing modalities also looking
at melanoma it's not just point mutation
but also amplification and deletion of
melanomas are becoming increasingly
important deletion of p16 and pink 10 as
well as amplifications are clinically
significant and targetable but
additionally b-raf fusions have been
recently identified in melanoma and
beans again are critical insignificance
these are activating fusions that are
again targetable by targeted
chemotherapy agents against beer a
finesse singling pathway so just looking
at different signaling pathways
indicates or cell from cell surface
receptors to your internal signaling
pathways a graph and rafts in committee
as well as
genes that are involved in DNA
modification being part and H tax drug
it's important that the drugs are being
developed for all of these chains shown
here and so there's been a tremendous
explosion in the number of genes that
are targetable today and there for me to
be able to test for activation because
all these genes within the cancer cells
specifically again but we're not know my
genetic alterations with targeted
therapy in clinical trials are showing
here for instance a number of
indications are being targeted in
clinical trials as well as copy number
changes including deletions and
amplifications and so it's important to
be able to evaluate all of these changes
for melanoma patients showing here is
this a sampling of clinical trials that
are studying targeted therapies in
melanoma and these include important
genes such as earthly foresee kits and
rass as well as pdgfr and other cell
surface signal molecules and so so for
patients it's important to evaluate all
these genetic pathways so that they have
the option of entering these clinical
trials as potentially their best option
for for therapy another important point
I want to make today is that full
sequencing of the genes is very
important compared to current modalities
that look only at hotspot when the
sequence the entire Jane all base pairs
in each team is in violated and multiple
readings of each gene verify the
accuracy and quantifies it variability
among them within that gene and in this
way obligations are identified in
contrast to hotspot intentions and it's
really look at single base pair of
changes at one area in the genes so
these hotspot palos sometimes can
combine multiple
genes that still are only looking at a
very limited focus within the gene and
instill demonstrated that's hot spot
intentions can miss the other mutations
in the same thing gunner that are
clinically important in actionable
there's been several studies which
demonstrate this that have come out
recently so importantly up to twenty
percent of actionable chaos mutations
are missed by looking at hot spots alone
in addition I've mentioned previously BF
there's additional locations outside and
v600e and mass as well there are a
number of mutations outside of the
hotspot regions so for instance in the
case of chaos this means that up to
twenty percent of colon cancer patients
could inappropriate and be offered
cetuximab repented to map based on
hotspot testing alone and so it's
important to identify these patients and
entering them more appropriate
appropriately as I mentioned earlier the
NCCN guidelines for evaluation and
treatment of patients have been rapidly
changing for many cancers and this is
based on clinical studies and FDA
approvals so for instance in my cancer
now being nccn guidelines recommend that
egfr now Kapini evaluating in the
context of a multi gene by Gene
next-generation sequencing panel in
addition a number of new drugs have been
approved within the very rapid studies
and therefore the time to clinical trial
to ft an approval that has been
shortened and and therefore additional
fda-approved drugs are coming online and
at much rapid pace and we need to be
prepared to identify those patients
appropriately another important point to
make today is that multi-gene testings
becoming part of the clinical trials
paradigm
in the past the drug was new drugs were
given to a wide range of patients and
then biomarker steins will perform
currently biomarker studies are
performed upfront to identify patients
who have the best chance and respond to
targeted therapies and so I just in
these political trials multiplex
next-generation sequencing testing is
required to enter the trial so what is
the definition of next-generation
sequencing its massive parallel
sequencing of feeling or cdna the test
generally can sequence greater than 900
billion base pairs of DNA in as little
as four hours currently there are two
big platforms like technologies which
uses the Ion Torrent Personal Genome
oisin and aluminum which has the high
seat my second XE sequencers several
different DNA preparation techniques and
applications our example for
next-generation sequencing platforms you
can take secret cell genome whole exome
were all exons of all genes or else
targeted libraries with looking at all
exons of certain genes large panels of
genes there's also pcr-based hotspot
regions which can be sequenced by
next-generation sequencing as well as
our they seek to look at RNA expression
textured areas in sequencing of the
cancer gene panels as shown here genomic
sequence of sequencing of the entire
coding regions or all exons of the genie
is performed in this way greater than
400 genes can be sequenced in a single
assay from a 40 micron section or an
unstained slides of an ffpe tissue block
each gene is sequence many times up to
500 times to increase the sensitivity
the base paired in patients insertions
deletions copy number changes and
translocations can identify all at once
in these
gene panels so next-generation
sequencing based succulent profiling is
now commercially available to all
appropriate patients q group
electrodiagnostic slab offers a cancer
plex test with sequences 413 genes and
improves amplifications and deletions as
well as translocations another test from
foundation one from balconies medicine
again offers a large tool panels and
that also includes copy number changes
internal occasions just shown
schematically here a review that the
technique of the technology balance
perform basically we start with a tissue
extraction of ffpe tissue whether that's
the tissue block or unstained slides
that are macro dissecting but the basic
principle is to isolate the tumor tissue
into the intimate term and extract DNA
sure here is the schematic
next-generation sequencing pipeline for
Larkin panels basically they would
create a library of the genes that were
interested in and so we capture just the
DNA that were interested in sequencing
and then at the uninteresting our car
krog extra DNA is removed and we
purified the exons of interest
condemning sequence an important part of
the process is the final data analysis
and bioinformatics and alignment of the
genes to the reference DNA is a is a
massive undertaking that requires a
processing power and paving a
significant player and thematic support
just shows schematically here is the
library preparation process as I
mentioned we extract DNA I shown at this
stage and then the DNA is fragmented and
we hybridize those findings of being and
with our probes which pulled on in areas
of interest and that's done that's shown
here on the upper right where our probes
bind to the DNA and protons fragments of
DNA that were interested in sequencing
and then those secrets are loaded into
the sequencer for final data processing
this process takes several days to
complete and then the final data
analysis is undertaking once again can
take 24 to 48 hours so the cancer plex
gene payroll offered by the Q group is
1.5 Megan basis of the enabler sequence
and that encompasses 413 great reporting
cancer genes then on average we sequence
each gene at greater than 500 times and
this increases our sensitivity to
identify subpopulations of tumor cells
with genetic alterations and also allows
us to test a mixed population of cells
so we don't need one or two present pure
cancer cells the test analyzes single
base pair changes with 99 percent
sensitivity we also can't act small
insertions and deletions with greater
than ninety three percent sense to me we
can identify any notifications and
deletions as well as translocations in
Clinton important genes alpharetta lost
one with greater than one hundred
percent when a hundred percent
sensitivity had a hundred percent of
purity and with tumor purity of fifty
percent
we have a sensitivity of ninety percent
importantly there's no false positives
that are identified for translocations
shown schematically here is confirmation
of translocation that we are identified
by next-generation sequencing on the
upper left we have the EML for gene
which is rearranged in further he out
demon on the right and on the upper
panel work we've identified this
translocation and our next-generation
sequencing panel and this has been
confirmed by Sanger sequencing again
where we identify that the 59 portion of
eligible for gene which is translated in
front of the the alkene so we can
officially identify these translocations
based on DNA sequencing okay also
identify copy number changes shown here
is the amplification of the her2/neu
gene or the herb beef early to consider
that shown in the middle and we are able
to connect hgf 4g by pfft far on the
right we turn on the left is partial
amplification of acidic 812 jeans so in
this portion we have increased number of
reads of this portion of the gene and on
the right is the normal number of normal
copy numbers of the gene of cdk 12 so
this is partially identification so the
clinical utility of next generation
profiling has been demonstrated by
several publications initially back in
2013 sharing that actually will alter a
shins are identified in seventy-six
percent of tumors meaning that pankaj
etic driver mutations in genetic
alteration to identify in seventy-six
percent of tumors which is three times
the number of changes that are
identified by current diagnostic tests
let's look at single genes signal jeans
at a time
results from the q cancer Plex tests
have shown greater than ninety three
percent actionable results in greater
than 20 types of cancer so the cancer
Plex test reports several different
categories the most important ones that
are actually well that we consider that
are considered actionable are variants
associated with approved fda approved
targeted therapies for instance in
graphene six other indications of
melanoma and indications that are
associated with therapies and clinical
development which includes
amplifications or mutations in her2 gene
in colon cancer patients currently there
are clinical trials studying targeted
therapies for those patients so shown
here schematically is the only state and
evaluation of a cancer patient this is a
colon cancer patient interior is removed
now / right processed a new character
block and a dynamic back histology under
the microscope and a pathology a
generator import of colon cancer and a
physician receives a pathology report
must assert determine the treatment plan
based on that physicians experience with
these different drugs and personal
preference and so surely here on right
this all the fda-approved drugs for
colon cancer however guidelines note
that they connect genetic testing for
colon cancer patient first it's the NCCN
guidelines now recommend sequencing for
chaos and invest teams as well as BF and
all of you and ogden colon cancer
diagnosis and also the guidelines
recommend on sequencing or evaluation
for lip syndrome genes and importantly
multiple hotspot tests are expensive and
convert all of these genes that are
including large gene panels and also the
hotspot tests have been demonstrated to
be inadequate and identifying all the
clinically significant
mkay Stinson and grass capacity wrath
and so there's a involving new standard
evaluation for the colon cancer patient
after the patient's diagnosis of colon
cancer now generate the FFPE tissue
block and in addition to dying in
histology the tumor sample is a diary by
next-generation sequencing panel and so
the pathology report generated a
diagnosis of colon cancer and that
diagnosis is combining two comprehensive
lucky the profiling test just to show
the power of this technique now in a
case example we have a 46 year old man
with a newly diagnosed stage 3 colon
cancer the cancer flex test was I was
requesting you identify no mutations in
K rats and rats or BF so in this case
the patient is eligible for syntax map
and panitumumab treatment however the
test also identified education and
amplification and that her two or early
to gene and this occurs approximately
seven percent of colon cancer patients
and in this particular case
amplification of the her2 gene was
confirmed by fish analysis and so eric
peter inhibitors are being dialing it in
clinical trials for for GI cancers you
may be familiar with the utilization of
her to nibblers for gastric cancer but
these are also being evaluated for colon
cancer patients and so for this
particular case now that position uses
the kids up Lex test along with the
pathology report to guide the best
therapy so the best first-line targeted
therapy for this patient is herb attacks
or effective x and tuna and there's also
a second-line therapy you know available
or clinical trial available after this
patient dot was May received or
something to target that amplification
invitation in her too
so just to summarize the results of the
cancer Plex testing of the tumor types
tested to date approximately thirty
percent of the test represent colon
cancers twenty-five percent or lung
cancers six percent melanoma and thirty
percent of advanced breast cancer and
then a variety of other sites so
importantly approximately forty percent
of the samples anxiety come from
coraline a melanoma or genetic testing
required between proclaiming in sixty
percent of the cases are websites were
no fda-approved target apartment therapy
exists importantly vast majority of
cases representing diagnosis and
treatment naive patients and as I
mentioned earlier actionable results
have been found in greater than nineteen
percent of patients analyzed in forty
percent of these direct results are
actually will do to essentially with
approved fda approved therapy in sixty
percent of cases results are identifying
driving cases that are being studied in
clinical trials and importantly in
eighty-five percent in cases the
constellation of findings could only be
a team to a large gene panel in olin
fifteen percent of the cases could
results have been achieved by killing
standard recommended single gene testing
so now i'd like to present case examples
in the first case is in 52 year old man
with stage four marley preventing
squamous cell carcinoma of the buccal
mucosa mrs. metastatic lymph nodes p16
stating was negative in this patient and
the cancer plex test identified
mutations in the patch tool as well as
p53 somatic american activating
mutations impacts are found in ninety
percent of spread basal cell carcinoma
and get and can be seen in a fraction of
next wave of cell carcinoma loss of
function of mutations loss-of-function
mutations are patched it's the
activation of smoothened and downstream
hedgehog signaling
so this particular mutation has been
observed in basal cell cancer as well as
colon cancer analyzing advisory region
with known in vacuum activating
mutations so in this case the patient is
eligible for this model give which
targets the Hedgehog singing pathway and
is being studied in clinical trials for
head neck squamous cell carcinoma so the
next case is in 31 year old man with
cutaneous melanoma and enlarged lymph
nodes in the neck and FMA of the lymph
node show metastatic disease in a cell
block of this FNA was sent for testing
cancer Plex identified an oncogenic
mutation in n wrasse and activating
mutation and meka 1g importantly
mutations enter and mass are associated
with between fifteen and twenty percent
of melanoma in this queue 61 are
mutation is the most frequently new
tenant variant connect to our sorry mech
one is a is sim is an important member
of the wrasse map lakay kinase signaling
pathway which transmits signals from the
cell surface to the nucleus and this
mutation that has identified has also
been seen as a resistance mechanism to
dubrovnik in beer a positive melanomas
so it's an important mutation that can
mediate resistance to the approved
therapy importantly inhibitors that
directly target and mass are not
available however clinical trials are
studying therapies for the stores
molecular profile an important in cdk4
inhibitors are been combined with mek1
endeavors in patients with this
particular molecular profile in addition
the test identified a mutation in bath 1
VAP one which has been shown to be a
target of both somatic and germline
mutations in cancer importantly germline
mutations have a role in containment
melanoma as well as other cancers
to complete phenotypic spectrum of
tumors and Babylon communications and
dep on mutation carriers remains to be
defended your games to be defined
however back when germline mutations
have been suggested to result and
disorder with many different cancer
types of varying disease and very
penetrance and so that's going to get a
patient additional germline testing may
be warranted the next case is a 61 year
old man with advanced to pata de celular
carcinoma and so for this patient
first-line treatment is saravia which
the pension started 1 year ago the
patient has been stable but he's now
progressing so the cancer Plex test was
performed on a tumor vaccine from 2013
ensure a mutation in the tsc one gene
our research analysts here at the Q
group identified tsc1 as a key component
of mtor signaling pathway and the
indeterminate this mutation likely leads
to up-regulation of mtor signaling
important enter activation has been
shown to mediate raffinate resistance in
Nevada senator carcinoma in a recent
publication in molecular cell proteomics
so clinical trials are studying
temsirolimus which targets the mtor
pathway in combination therapies for
hepatocellular carcinoma and oncologist
treating this patient is considering
adding temsirolimus which is FDA
approved for canasta renal cell
carcinoma the next case is a 61 year old
woman with lung cancer metastatic to the
kidney previous text testing showed
wild-type EGFR and no translocation and
out gene the tumor had progressed on
standard chemotherapy a core needle
biopsy of the kidney metastases assented
acute molecular diagnostics lab for
cancer Plex testing we identified an
uncommon be representation g-46 9p that
would not have been detected by can
methods that I'm detective e 600 e / k
so Trebek nib and the traveler the
graphing a combination therapy is
approved option for be 600 melanoma for
other beer applications there are
clinical trials studying this
combination therapy and specifically
from lung cancer bereft inhibition by M
raffinate or get back to graphing it
have been reported to be effective in
early clinical trials in the oncologist
in this case use the results of the test
take an insurance coverage for traumatic
drag and drop the grafted treatment for
this patient the next case is a 59 year
old woman with high-grade sarcoma in
chest cavity which was surrounding the
heart now there are no approved targeted
therapies available for this patient the
kids Plex test should hurt too and 19 21
mutations the mutation in her v 2 or her
to is in growth factor receptor domain
and is likely activating an important
that clinical trials are other study
abusive lapatinib and other agents which
targeted which target hurting gene in
patients whose tumors harboring
mutations in this team in addition idh1
mutation is an enzymatic debate domain
event of a gene other mutations in this
domain have been seen in up to
seventy-five percent of glue from yamas
and likely are activating so clinical
trials are studying target therapy in
patients whose killer Harbor idh1
mutations the next case is a 58 year old
man with non-small cell lung cancer
current testing shared wild-type EGFR
know how translocation the cancer Plex
test identified and a g12 mutation in
and rats
so n rest testing is not intended
performed for lung cancer however
endress communications have been a jerk
and up to one percent of lung cancers in
criminal trials this specific variant
has been seen in a number a number of
times in a variety of cancers and is
likely in support of importance in
target on clinical trials are studying
the use of mek inhibitors for patients
with advanced legal tumors and so this
patient would be an ideal candidate for
this clinical trial the next case is a
64 year old woman with excellent mass
sharing infiltrating ductal carcinoma
there's er- p r+ and he returned was
equivalent at 2 plus the kids up Lex
tests showed a an activating mutation
will pi3 kinase gene this is a hotspot
mutation has been seen a number of times
in large sequencing projects and sternly
conveys an oxygen potential and
important clinical trials are studying
ever envelope ever alamos in other
targeted therapies targeting the
cleaning apt mtor signaling pathway i'm
showing here schematically not on on
this panel is the different types of
mutations that can be seen I end up i
think it's-- gene in our two hotspots
shown here and the mutations identified
in this patient represented a hotspot
and activating mutation in the in the
action in the kinase region of the gene
the next case is a 67 year old man with
admin carcinoma of the colon and what
that was metastatic to deliver can't
request testing revealed no mutations in
kos or and rest it did show an uncommon
mutation in DMF although less common
than v600e mutation has been described
in colon cancer
and it occurs in kinase domain and is
likely activating the raft mutations in
general reduce the effectiveness of
anti-egfr therapy with respond suring it
from a percent in caries appear at
mutations verses thirteen percent in
wild-type patients although one patient
with this specific d 5 for 19 mutation
did respond to the thoughts about plus
chemotherapy common combination therapy
and important clinical trials are
studying combination therapies
strengthening plus approximate and other
targeted therapies and patients with
beer applications in addition of p53
mutation was identified in this patient
so in this particular case the
oncologist played the starts a tux back
and consider combination therapy for
this patient the next case is a 35 year
old women with breast cancer that was
the rfp are positive and her t- that was
metastatic to deliver now this patient
normally would be treated with hormonal
therapy as well as chemotherapy and the
cancer Plex test revealed a mutation in
the estrogen receptor that renders the
patient not responsive to hormonal
therapy and so therefore that you know
the testing identified a patient which
would be resistant to hermano therapy
and therefore additional treatment
modalities need to be explored they're
partly a test revealed a communication
enable gene when political trials are
spending the news of monotony of
impatience these two more hybrid
mutations in the naval one gene
the next case is in 92 year old man with
squamous cell carcinoma metastatic
Turner lymph node and nope targeted
therapies are available for this type of
cancer patient however the kids reflex
test shared imitations in kits and mtor
the kid mutation a 6 1 T is in the
tyrosine kinase domain name is likely
activating and importantly there's
fda-approved drugs magnum and other
targeted therapies that are approved for
other cancer than complications other
business patients and that are being
studied in clinical trials also the
mutation the mtor has been has not been
pretty previously characterized however
mtor inhibitors are approved for cancers
other than ms patients and again
political treasure studying combination
therapies for patients with tumors from
Harbor and tour mutations so one of the
final points I'd like to make today is
that precision therapies are also being
recognized as more cost-effective for
instance for non-small cell lung cancer
patients one cancer patients multiplex
genetic screening is cost effective
compared to standard chemotherapy and
without molecular testing in metastatic
setting and these have been now there
are several publications demonstrating
this not supposed to own cancer that
receive molecular guided or targeted
therapies are effective for tumors with
egfr mutations and alkyl rangements
however these mutations have a low
frequency overall in these patients and
therefore there's an incremental
cost-effectiveness and in the tested
cheap compared to treatment with with
these targeted therapies and so there's
a significant gain in the quality of
life and and the survival in these
patients and so in summary there's a
significant cost effectiveness in
patients who receive multiplex genetic
screening and in our car placed on
luckily guided targeted therapies so
just to finish with the references which
are included in the handout and i think
i'll stop the presentation at this point
and be available for any additional
questions
well thank you dr. Lau that informative
presentation I'm thrilled to be part of
the cardinal health lab exchange before
we start the question answer session I'd
like to remind our audience that you can
submit your questions by typing them
into the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the Q&A button on the lower
left hand corner of the presentation
screen well answer as many questions as
we can let's wait a second to see if
anyone submits any questions meanwhile
I'd like to take this opportunity to
thank our sponsored Cardinal Health for
making today's educational webcasts
possible also I'd like to remind
everyone to please head over to the
community of learning following this
today's presentation and have the
opportunity to engage in a live chat
with dr. Lyle as well as your peers and
have questions answered in regard to
personalized medicine comprehensive
next-generation sequencing for cancer
patients so if there are no questions at
this time I'd like to thank everyone and
thank you dr. Lyle and remind everyone
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through October of
this year you will receive an email from
lab words alerting you to whether to win
this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time thanks again normal and take
care bye